he takes huge dramatic pauses
yeah especially when he's about to
mention dog poop like it's just too
too much i don't want to even say it
howard stern takes aim at johnny depp
amid the actor's defamation trial
against his ex-wife amber heard i was
completely unaware of how entertaining
the johnny depp amber heard trial is on
monday the 68 year old radio personality
slammed the pirates of the caribbean
star who is suing his ex for defamation
after she alluded to their alleged
abusive relationship in a 2018 op-ed
piece written for the washington post
stern calls johnny a huge narcissist the
trial has been live streaming since
april 11th and during siriusxm's the
howard stern show monday the radio host
said he thinks johnny is all for having
it televised quote that's what
narcissists do they say i will charm the
pants off of america at the trial adding
that they think they can talk their way
out of anything
yeah the best-selling author isn't
having it adding that both amber and
johnny sound like two battling children
before adding that the oscar winner who
testified over multiple days
is totally over acting on the stand if
you notice he takes huge dramatic pauses
yeah especially when he's about to
mention dog poop like it's just too
too much i don't want to even say it
howard references that one moment in
particular when johnny claims amber
defecated in their bed in 2016 and
blamed it on their dogs
on
my side of the bed
was human fecal matter my initial
response to that
was
i mean i laughed
it was so
outside
it was so bizarre and she just tried to
blame it on the dogs
their teacup yorkies they weigh about
four pounds each
i lived with those dogs for many years
that did not come from a dog
that just didn't
your honor
was the size of the dog
your honor have you ever taken a [ __ ] as
big as you are i don't think so i rest
my case if i was auditioning for
saturday night live this would be my
monologue for lorne michael yes i
thought that some
human being had actually
dropped a
grumpy
pardon the term
on to the bed the lawyers must have
lectured johnny depp on how to refer to
feces because he called it dropping a
grumpy what
i thought that some
human being had actually
dropped a
grumpy
oh but howard wasn't done throwing shade
at johnny he also called out the
kentucky born actor's accent quote does
that sound like a guy from kentucky
as was my regular practice there had
been an altercation she was
she had
some
rage issue with me
johnny's cross-examination ended on
monday and while amber has yet to
testify she's expected to in the coming
days
[Music]
you